If you’re a Kevin Smith fan, you may already
be familiar with Jay and Silent Bob’s cameo
in Scream 3, but you might not know the
backstory behind it. Jay and Silent Bob are
a pair of characters that first appeared in Kevin
Smith’s 1994 movie, Clerks, which is prominently
displayed at the video store in the original
Scream. Jay and Bob would become recurring
characters who show up in many Kevin Smith
films that are part of his View Askewniverse,
and as a thank you for the free advertising
in Scream, Kevin Smith and Scream director Wes
Craven decided to exchange cameos in each other’s
movies. So, Jay and Silent Bob show up in Scream 3,
and the following year, Wes shows up in Jay
and Silent Bob Strike Back, where he plays
Wes Craven the director of Scream 4, a decade
before Wes would actually create Scream 4.
In addition to that, Cotton Weary’s
apartment in the opening of Scream
3 contains a copy of Chasing Amy, which
is also part of the View Askewniverse.
The scene with Jay and Silent Bob also contains
a couple other cameos, which are pretty much only
findable thanks to the retrospective documentary
Still Screaming, which points out a cameo from Wes
Craven as the man with a video camera, and Scream
3’s casting director Lisa Beach as the tour guide.
To learn how Scream 3 may have had a second
killer who died before being revealed,
stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
In Scream, movies don’t create psychos,
movies make psychos more creative.
In Scream 2, movies are a scapegoat for someone
who is planning to be a killer. Scream 3 reverses
this and has the killer make the movie,
creating his own lore every step of the way.
Welcome to Things You Missed. Wanting
to capitalize on the hype train created
by Scream 1 and 2, producers decided to go
ahead without screenwriter Kevin Williamson,
by replacing him with Ehren Kruger.
Really? The creator of A Nightmare
On Elm Street is working with a guy named Kruger?
– [Jennifer] Stage name.
– You should talk, Judy Jurgenstern.
– [Group] OHHHHH!!!!!
– Sidney Prescott has become
a crisis hotline counselor,
and she also takes on a stage name of
sorts, going by Laura to her callers.
She’s unknowingly following in the footsteps
of her mother, who used the name Rina Reynolds
while working in Hollywood. There’s a
running theme of pseudonyms in Scream 3.
Most of our main characters are actors
who are just as likely to respond to
their character names as their actual names,
to the point that it becomes kind of a joke.
– Not “Sidney”, Sidney. Like
I’m “Gale” and she’s Gale.
– Obviously, it’s more than just a joke
though, it’s important to the plot,
because Roman’s changing of
his last name to Bridger is
what helps disguise his true identity
as Sidney’s brother and the killer.
Let’s get into the Things You Missed.
(brooding music)
(knives slashing)
As with Screams 1 and 2, the opening shows
the slaying of a couple, only this time,
we recognize one of the victims, it’s
Cotton Weary and his girlfriend. Cotton
is complaining that he is only given a cameo
in Stab 3, which is basically his experience in
Scream 3 -- despite being a big part of the second
movie, they kill him off right away in this one.
One the criticisms of turning Scream into a
franchise was that it would become the very
thing that the original Scream was satirizing, and
we see this intentionally, or not intentionally in
Scream 3’s opening. In the last film, Stab 1
attempted to recreate the opening of Scream,
the death of Casey Becker. But certain
things are embellished for Hollywood,
like how they add a shower scene which seems to
have no purpose other than showing a little skin.
So Scream 3’s opening literally does that,
in the form of Cotton’s girlfriend getting
out of the shower. There’s even a shot of
Christine’s towel dropping by her feet,
very similar to Casey’s bathrobe in Stab.
– The whole shower thing’s
been done! Vertigo. Hello?
– It’s not Vertigo, it’s Psycho. As we have
discussed many times on this show. Then,
Then, Christine even channels her inner Casey Becker
herself when she kicks Ghostface to get away.
Scream 2’s opening was all about the Stab movie
premiere, so there’s a slight nod to that as well,
when Cotton is frantically driving home, he nearly
hits a bus with a Stab 2 advertisement on back.
This next one might not be a reference,
this might just be Cotton being entirely
focused on saving his girlfriend, but he
leaves his car door open as he goes inside,
much like Bob Simms in Halloween, who
was also probably focused on one thing
entirely. As you know if you’ve seen Scream,
Halloween is basically considered the big one,
and is referenced all the time. But not that
much in Scream 3. Although there is the one
part where Sidney hears her mother’s voice
telling her she’ll protect her from the
Boogeyman. The Boogeyman is a pseudonym
for Michael Myers in the Halloween films.
Ghostface tries to pressure Cotton into revealing
the location of Sidney Prescott before offing him,
and then we see Sidney living a secluded
life with her dog. By her door there’s
a Fall of Troy poster advertising the
play she was in in college, Agamemnon.
Does that mean she actually went
through with being in the play
after defeating Mickey and Debbie
on it’s stage? That’s dedication.
She also continues to wear the Greek letters
given to her by her boyfriend when the murders
were happening in the last movie. Can you really
blame her? He was the best guy she ever dated.
The next character we meet is Gale Weathers,
who is giving a speech about being a journalist
lady. A woman in the crowd is wearing a #81
jersey. Not many people know this, but Scream
1996 was not the first… or last… slasher movie to
be called Scream. The original was a 1981 film.
I have not seen it, but according to the
Letterboxd ratings, it is not very good.
This scene also has the best extra. This
lady is REALLY into Gale’s speech. This
speech is part of a lecture series
called FW Bestor Lecture Series:
Faces of Journalism, named after the movie’s
art department coordinator Claudia Bestor.
Just like the last two movies, Sidney is at home,
when she sees bad news on the TV
that involves her and her past.
As we’re first introduced to Sunrise Studios,
where most of this movie takes place, we hear
the song Red Right Hand by Nick Cave and the Bad
Seeds, which by this point is more or less the
Scream theme song, this is our fourth time hearing
it, and the end credits would be the fifth,
although that one is a special Scream 3
version meant to close out the trilogy.
Stab 3’s subtitle is “Return to Woodsboro”, and
this phrase keeps finding new meaning throughout
the movie. It’s actually a leftover from Kevin
Williamson’s original outline for the script,
that he planned after writing Scream 2, but most
of it was not used for what would become Scream
3. We would symbolically return to Woodsboro
immediately, because they’re shooting on the
Woodsboro set. Sidney would return to Woodsboro
when she is later chased through this set.
Later still, the focus of the story is brought
back to Woodsboro when we learn new information
about the motivations of Billy and Stu. And the
movie would end with everyone returning Woodsboro,
or at least what appears to be Woodsboro
to join Sidney at her secluded home.
But this first scene on the Woodsboro set
contains more depth than what meets the eye.
(cinematic impact)
(mysterious music)
When we meet Roman, the director of Stab 3,
he’s busy making a case for keeping the
production going after Cotton’s death.
– [Roman] Hire more security, hire the
national guard, just don’t kill the movie.
– Which is funny, because he literally would
kill the movie, at least for the time being,
by killing everyone in it. He’s seen arguing
with a studio executive played by Roger Corman,
who tells him that violence in cinema is kind of
a no-no right now. Which is also a little joke,
because Roger Corman is a well known
horror producer and director. He literally
made movies such as Night of the Blood
Beast. A Bucket of Blood. Bloody Mama.
Battle of Blood Island. Blood Bath.
A remake of A Bucket of Blood.
But his concern over gory movies in 1999
was very relevant, because Stab 3 is the
in-universe stand-in for Scream 3, and Scream
3 was going through the same problems at this
time thanks to the Columbine Massacre, the
worst high school shooting of the millenium.
The Columbine Massacre was carried out by two high
school seniors, and that is really only similarity
to Scream that exists, but that didn’t stop
people who were already against horror movies.
– Everybody that didn’t like horror films that was
in a position of power, came after the studios.
– [Zac] Columbine happened in April 1999.
Scream 3 started shooting in July,
so there was a lot of pressure from the studio
to limit the gore, which is why we see less of
it in this movie. According to Matthew Lillard,
he was already paid to appear in Scream 3 as the
returning villain Stu Macher, but Columbine put
an end to those plans. Wes Craven attempted to
make sure the cultural context was not
forgotten, by sneaking in this article
about Columbine into the scene where Sidney
looks through her file at the police station.
The other articles in this file are just nonsense.
Look at this one. “The local police chief,
the first official commissioned by
the city with the search committed
in the name of the parents. The shadowy
suspect, faces 121 charges of murder,
kidnapping, arms, smuggling, fraud
and theft. 'His plea is he hadn’t
committed these offenses.' said the parents’
attorney, 'we will find the Megan at all cost.'"
When Gale, that is, the
real Gale, shows up on set,
she’s hit by that wave of dreadful familiarity.
(creepy music)
– Deja Voodoo.
– Her misuse of the term déjà vu,
right outside of Sidney’s house,
calls back to Sidney’s own misuse of the phrase in
Scream 1. The nostalgia does not end there though,
because the new Gale, aka Jennifer,
is dressed more like the old Gale.
But what happens next is not all old
and familiar. Gale runs into Dewey,
who has become an advisor for the
movie. When these two met in Scream 2,
Dewey was upset with how Gale
portrayed him in her book. Now,
Dewey has turned the tables on her, and Gale is
upset about how he’s portraying her in Stab 3.
In my previous Scream analysis videos, I
pointed out Wes Craven’s easter eggs to his
other major horror franchise, A Nightmare on
Elm Street. We don’t really get that much in
the third one, but there is this one
tiny nightmare scene involving Sidney,
where she sees her dead mother come to the window.
If we’re being honest though, the reference
points a lot more towards Salem’s Lot than
it does towards Freddy Krueger.
The next day, Sarah Darling,
who plays the character Candy in Stab, has a
meeting with Roman at the production office.
– I’m Candy, the chick who gets
killed second I’m only in two scenes.
– Like Cotton’s gripes about his character,
the complaint about her screen time could
also apply to her role in Scream 3; she’s only in
2 scenes. There’s also another 1:1 parallel later,
where the police mention that there are three
versions of the Stab 3 script, in order to
try to keep the ending off the internet -- the
exact same approach used for Scream 3. And then
there’s the romance between Dewey and Gale.
This time, rather than art imitating life,
life would imitate art. These two got married
for realsies right before they started shooting.
Anyway, during the line reading, Roman goes off
the script, and then claims there’s a new version.
– It’s not just a new script, it’s a new movie.
– What movie?
– My movie.
– Although we don’t know it yet,
she’s speaking to the real Roman,
and he’s telling the truth. By
killing the people involved in Stab 3,
he’s creating the lore for Stab
3. He’s creating his movie.
Candy is the successor to Tatum in Scream, and
her death closely resembles Tatum’s. Ghostface
chases her into the prop room where, among
all the movie props, is a fridge. Remember,
Tatum went to the garage to get drinks
from the fridge. She’s punched through
a door where she’s left hanging
on her stomach, and this is where
Ghostface get her. She dies in the exact same
position that Tatum died in in the pet flap.
While Gale and Dewey are out to lunch
to discuss their past relationship,
Gale emphasizes the importance of leaving
him alone to go on the sequel to 60 minutes,
claiming she could have been the next Diane
Sawyer. It’s a bit of a Scream 2 reference,
Diane Sawyer was the journalist that Cotton
most wanted to be interviewed on to gain fame.
Back on the movie set, we have maybe our
most obvious set of crew reference easter
eggs yet on the director’s chairs. Yes, they
are called that. This one’s for Peter Deming,
the Director of Photography, this
one belongs to Sheila Waldron,
the script supervisor and there’s one for
Bruce Alan Miller, the production designer.
That evening, the cast gathers for the
depressing wrap party at Jennifer’s house,
where the killing continue with her
security guard, and Roman continues to
quote unquote write his movie by
literally sending in script pages
telling them what to do via fax. Uhh, if
you don’t know what fax is, look it up.
The house blows up, taking
out Tom, aka: the new Dewey,
and the old Gale punches the new Gale
in the face, this is yet another twist
on the Scream tradition, of Ms. Weathers
getting a facefull of knuckles in each film.
The characters end up at the police station
where they’re finally reunited with Sidney.
One nice detail at the station is the
display of movie posters and books about
film. It’s like Randy suggested in Scream 1,
that the cops should study movies to save time.
Speaking of Randy, he makes his return, in
the form of a post-mortem video message,
which he would use to communicate
a few new horror movie rules.
(cinematic impact)
– [Randy] True trilogies are all about
going back to the beginning and
discovering something that wasn’t
true from the get-go. Godfather,
Jedi, all revealed something that we
thought was true, that wasn’t true.
– This was not his first time referencing
the original Star Wars trilogy, we saw
him mention it in Scream 2, and it wouldn't be long before it came up again.
The two Gales meet the Sunrise Studios archivist, who is played byCarrie Fisher,
aka, Princess Leia in Star Wars.
– I was up for Princess Leia. I was this close. So
who gets it? The one who sleeps with George Lucas.
– She also shares something in common with Sidney,
her trilogy also involves the surprise twist
where she discovers someone is her brother.
They pull out the file for Maureen Prescott,
who at the time was going by Rina Reynolds. At
the bottom of her resume, we can see that
she started her acting career in theatre,
just as her daughter would go on to do. One of
the plays she was in was even called I Want To
Scream. So they’ve got a whole little family
involved in the dramatic arts. Maureen with
her acting in plays and horror films; Roman,
the director; and Sidney, the live performer.
If Candy’s death was a callback to Tatum, this
scene where Sidney is chased through the movie set
is a repeat of her own scene in Scream, right down
to her screwing herself by locking herself in with
Ghostface at the front door. There’s also another
similarity. In Scream, she calls the police
using this program on her computer, and Dewey
immediately shows up at her door. In Scream 3,
she literally just yells out for Dewey and he comes
running because he’s already at the studio.
The cops show up and we see this one new cop named
“J West”. This is the last crew reference easter
egg, it’s a reference to the assistant
production coordinator John Burton West.
After discovering Maureen worked in the movies,
Dewey and the Gales confront the producer
John Milton, who basically tells them that
he held these parties back in the day where
industry bigwigs took advantage of actresses,
and he basically turned a blind
eye to this illegal activity.
If you’ve followed the entertainment industry
recently, this might sound familiar. In 2018
film producer Harvey Weinstein was arrested
as many allegations came out against him,
some of which dated back to the 1970s,
the very same time period that John
Milton claimed to have these parties.
Could this be a coincidence? Maybe not.
From my understanding, Weinstein got away
with this for as long as he did because he
targeted small time actresses. They did
not take legal action because they were
afraid they’d be blacklisted from the industry,
since Harvey had contacts with all of Hollywood.
For example, two actresses up for
parts in Lord of the Rings lost
their roles simply because Weinstein
told Peter Jackson that they were a
“nightmare to work with.” That’s
the kind of influence that he had.
But with the advent of the internet and social
media, the victims were able to discover that they
were not the only ones. There were a lot. Like
a whole lot. So they came together, knowing that
they couldn’t ALL be blacklisted. The point of all
this is, while they didn’t get him arrested for
many years, there were rumors about Weinstein’s
behavior. So it’s very possible that Wes Craven
may have known about these rumors and pulled
the biggest power move of all time, by putting a
Harvey Weinstein character in his movie. Which by
the way was produced by Bob and Harvey Weinstein.
But unlike these relatively unknown
actresses, Wes Craven had already made
it in Hollywood. Weinstein couldn’t
do anything to him, and besides,
he was already nearing the end of his career.
And despite being the executive producer,
Harvey Weinstein couldn’t really stop Wes from
using Scream 3 to make this indirect accusation.
Because if he order Wes to change the John
Milton scene, he’s just gonna look guilty.
According to the film’s editor, Patrick
Lussier, in an article on Slate,
the only note to come from the Weinstein
brothers at all, came from Harvey’s brother, Bob,
he just had a note about the ending, which I’ll
get back to later in this video. So Wes had his
boss backed into a corner where he could not
give any notes. It’s got to be one of the most
legendary moves that Wes has ever made if this,
in fact, is not a total, huge coincidence.
– Hollywood is full of criminals
whose careers are flourishing.
– I'm not a criminal!
– Yeah, I don’t think it is. And to
further add to the suspicion,
some of the accusers are connected to the
Scream franchise. Rosanna Arquette is the
real life sister of David Arquette, Dewey.
And Rose McGowan, who plays Tatum in Scream,
is the onscreen sister of David Arquette. Angelina
Jolie, potentially has two characters named
after her in Scream 3, Jennifer Jolie
and Angelina Tyler who says this:
– I did not f*ck that pig Milton
to get a leading role just to die here
with second-rate celebrities like you two!
– The movie’s climax takes place at a mansion party
where Roman’s birthday is to be celebrated. While
we don’t realize it at the time, I don’t
think it’s any coincidence that Roman puts
his plan into action on his birthday, the day
he became Maureen Prescott’s bastard child.
The party splits up to explore the mansion
and Jennifer finds herself stuck in a passage
with Ghostface. She sees Dewey on the other
side of this soundproof glass barrier and
struggles to get his attention. This is the same
situation that the real Gale was in in Scream 2,
when she was unable to communicate
with him in the recording studio.
There's another repeat of a Scream 2
situation in the basement when Roman
is knocked out after falling down
the stairs, but his body blocks the
only exit. This is like when Sidney had to
climb over Mickey to escape the crashed car.
Roman uses his capture of Gale and
Dewey to lure Sidney into the house,
but she's prepared and greets him with her
hidden gun. Unfortunately for her, this is
the one time that she didn't deliver a follow up shot
to the head and it comes back back bite her.
The final confrontation takes place
in the secret screening room where
Roman was theoretically conceived. After
revealing himself as the killer there are
a couple more parallels to Scream 1, the
bringing out of a gagged victim and Roman
cocking his head just like Ghostface when he
first pinned down Sidney at her dad’s house.
After he is defeated, we’re treated to an
epilogue. We see Sidney essentially let
her guard down for the first time since
that fateful phone call a few years ago.
Then we see Detective Kincaid, the cop
from LA, who apparently came back with
her? He’s holding a bowl of
popcorn and says they’re about to start
a movie. So the Scream trilogy ends just
as it began, with popcorn and a movie.
I personally think this was supposed to be
the end of the series. By comparing the last
ever Scream scene to the first ever,
we see the changed state of the world,
before and after the defeat of Roman, the driving
force behind all of the bad things that happened
to Sidney in the 1990s. However, having only one
killer doesn’t follow the Scream formula. There
could be one more villain from the production
of Stab 3 who has yet to be taken care of.
(cinematic impact)
(CONTAGIOUS spooky dance music)
Earlier in this video I mentioned two darker
topics, Weinstein and Columbine. I stated that Wes
Craven and his editor only received one note on
the film and it came from the innocent of the two
brothers, Bob Weinstein. His idea was to remove
the second Ghostface to just focus on Roman.
The reason for this, or at least one of the
reasons, may have been teased in the film.
Remember the scene where the producers are
having a discussion with Roman about the
future of the film, emphasizing that
stringed instruments in cinema are a
big deal right now? A big reason for that was
Columbine. So the shooting may have also been
part of the reason that they moved away from
the initial concept of having two killers.
The accomplice was going to be Angelina Tyler,
the woman who was set to play the fictional
version of Sidney in Stab 3. You can still see
remnants of this storyline in the film. In fact,
some fans believe that Angelina is
still canonically the 6th Ghostface,
and she was killed before she ever
got the chance to reveal herself.
Her story is that she won
the role in a talent search,
but we later find she did this
by sleeping with the producer.
– [Tom] You gotta be praying this movie keeps going.
– Of course I am, but not at the expense
of people’s lives.
– [Zac] You either die a hero or live --
There are three main sequences that make Angelina
look guilty. The first is shortly after Jennifer’s
house explodes. She briefly disappears, and
comes down the hill well after everyone else,
almost like she knew where to jump to
avoid taking fall damage. This allows
her to completely miss the altercation with
Roman. Dewey asks her about her whereabouts,
and she never actually answers the question.
– [Angelina] Tom was in the house!
Then, there’s the bathroom scene, which by the way
is setup exactly like the school bathroom scene in
Scream 1. Sidney discovers her seemingly changing
into the Ghostface costume, but Angelina plays
it off as her wanting to take props as souvenirs
now that the movie is shut down. But what if this
is actually her getting caught, and, being the
actress that she is, talking her way out of it?
This could also be the reason that Roman decides
to kill her off. He probably figured that Sidney
knew she was guilty, and it was better to
get rid of her before she had the chance
to be arrested and interrogated, where
she could possibly give them both away.
He knew Sidney wouldn’t
accuse her immediately though,
because she wouldn’t want a repeat
of Cotton Weary on her conscience,
who went to jail because he was wrongfully
accused by Sid when she wasn’t quite 100% sure.
So I think Angelina makes up an excuse, quickly
scurries away, and goes into the sound stage to
finish putting on the Ghostface costume. When
Sidney goes into the movie set version of her
room, there are clearly two killers here,
someone is pushing on the door, and then
3 seconds later Ghostface is all the way on the
other side of the room, behind her in the window.
I think the one in the window is Angelina,
because the shoes we see during the struggle
are the exact same as the ones that Sidney noticed
under the bathroom stall. When the lights go on,
we get a better look at Angelina
wearing these shoes with a black…
Skirt? Uh... I don’t know the terminology
for this piece of clothing,
but the loose black fabric could easily
help her blend into the Ghostface cloak.
And the third sequence where she looks guilty
is Roman’s birthday party. Sure, they appear to
be using the buddy system for safety, but Roman
and Angelina are each one-on-one with a victim.
Dewey and Gale also poke around and find a
Ghostface mask, cell phone and voice changer,
in a closet. But these are not Roman’s
because he clearly has his own. I can
understand having a backup costume,
but why have a second voice changer?
Angelina was supposed to be with Tyson,
but she disappears, and Roman fakes his
death, just like Billy did. In hindsight,
he’s probably the one who taught Billy to
make that Hollywood level corn syrup mixture.
During the big reveal, Roman even suggests
that he gave Billy pointers on being a killer,
such as having a partner to
sell out once you get caught.
This means Roman probably
also had a disposable partner.
When we last see Angelina, she’s frantically
trying to leave the house. Could it be that at
this point, she knows Roman is done with
her, and she’s now fearing for her life?
Or is this just part of the act?
We don’t actually see her die,
she just gets stabbed in the
shoulder, and dragged out of view.
It is awfully inconclusive for a
Scream character to go out like this.
Maybe Scream 5 will feature Stu and
Angelina as the Ghostface killers.
Personally, I don’t think there’s a ton of
evidence to suggest she’s alive, though it
is definitely a small possibility. But I am of
the belief that she was the Roman’s accomplice,
and there’s a ton of evidence to support that. Let
me know your thoughts on Angelina in the comments.
Scream 3 was marketed as the last Scream.
The final act. The very end. So join me
next time on Things You Missed as I cover
Scre4m. Also known as Scream 4. Make sure
you subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week, RING the deathbell and select
all notifications and I will see you in Wes
Craven’s final movie. Assuming we both survive.
(spooky dance music)